Hồi lỗi vụ vừa chính thủ tường chính phủ phương án nghỉ tết nguyên đàn hành in không trong 2 mấy sấu,
kéo dài chính ngày từ mấy bốn tháng 2 đến 2 2 tháng 2,
1 năm ngày chính thức nối tiếp bốn ngày cuy tôn.
Theo để sốt, zippet bính ngọa hành in không trong 2 mấy sấu,
không trước biến trước sẽ được nghỉ từ ngày 1, 2 năm hành in không trong 2 mấy sấu,
tức 2 mấy tháng 6 tị đến 3 ngày 2, 2 năm hành in không trong 2 mấy sấu,
tức 1 sấu tháng 10 năm bình ngọt.
Công trước biến trước, cho lại làm việc ngày 28 tháng 2, tức 1 mấy tết.
Đối với người lao đồng, các cưới vào điều kiện thực tế và lịch nghỉ đối với công trước,
biến trước người sự dụng lao đồng bố chỉ lịch nghỉ tết âm lịch trong người lao đồng.
Cụ thế, zipp nghỉ tết âm lịch năm hành in không trong 2 mấy sấu,
lựa trọn 1 ngày cuy 5 tị và 1 ngày đầu năm bình ngọt.
Hóc 2 ngày cuy 5 tị và 3 ngày đầu năm bình ngọt.
Hóc 3 ngày cuy 5 tị và 2 ngày đầu năm bình ngọt.
Nếu được thông qua, đây sẽ làm năm thứ 2 liên tiếp kiên nghỉ tết kéo dài chính ngày,
nhờ liên kể cuy tôn.
Kinh nghi dài sẽ tạo thận lợi trong người dân bố chỉ đi lại,
mua 3 và 3 tại sâu thông của năm.